so up three
one more game with black i feel like
last time i was um i was a bit worried
from the opening so
i'll probably try and play something
else this time
yeah he's taking taking a little break
now
not so eager to get on with uh
get on with it after as after the first
game like after the first game
he probably felt that um he could have
done better in that one and
he just wanted to to get going but now
this is uh serious danger time frame so
it's more of a time to
sit back regroup have a little break
and try and get back in the game
what should i do okay i'll start with
knight f6
that cannot be too wrong
c4
i'll play e6
knight c3 should i go
bishop before d5 or c5
don't really know what line to choose
you know what i'll go c5 i feel like
playing one of those structures
e3 huh okay i'll go d5
we're going to get a kind of a
semi-terrace
system here
don't want to go along with the very
most symmetrical lines here so i'm
playing a6 and giving him
the opportunity to give me the
izalani i had this
with white against mamadirov and i
played
i played g3 myself
let's see if he um has some of the same
ideas
otherwise you could of course develop
along the lines of
bishop e2 then castles
and is this a pure transposition
to to the a6 slab
let me see the a6 live as you go knight
f3 e3
no you go knight c3 a6 queen c2 e6
knight f3 c5 dcd5 ed5
bishop e2 knight c6 and then castles
okay so it's a it's a direct
transposition except the queen is on d1
rather than c2
who that favors i don't know
i don't know jeff
um
what to do let's go bishop g4
didn't particularly want to move the
other bishop
and um
maybe i could have gone c4
it wasn't that convincing
it's got it's gotten thinking so that's
a good thing
clearly we're in the first in the first
uh couple of games where we're
both struggling a tad with
time management too much yapping
okay let me go roxy8
just a little waiting move
now for bishop b2 i would uh
take an f3 take on d4 and i would claim
that um his bishop pair doesn't really
matter
it doesn't really matter all that much
okay
so now this is i guess
not ideal but at least i didn't
didn't have to okay so now typically
once they go
94 you're gonna go bishop g6 if i take
an e2 that feels a little bit too soft
so i could could have taken an f3 and
then
bishop three that's basically the same
position as we get in the game
uh not sure if my
way of playing this actually improved my
prospects okay i gotta go d4
good or bad i gotta do this
but i'm i guess i'm playing for equality
here
for sure no illusions anymore of trying
to keep the game complicated playing for
a win and so on
yeah ed4 i probably will go b5
and uh just try and regain the pawn
bishop c6
this is your three games down dude
you cannot just simplify everything
like i don't get it
i don't get it one bit
maybe he thinks he's better here but i
don't really think he is
knight c5 i take on d4 knight a6
does not seem feasible because of queen
d6
well there's queen b7 but nobody really
plays that way
yeah i've just taken do one quick b6 and
they're much slowly fine
before i go a5 and
no worries maybe after knight d7 is
technically
just a smidgen
better but here there's nothing
okay now he starts to play for a win
okay cool
let me go b4 try and improve those pawns
a bit
rook c6 i think there was kind of play
with rook d1
and uh yeah whenever yeah rook d8 d2
there is rook c8 so i gotta watch out
for that
okay let's go between d6
queen d5 next possibly
and i don't think i'm even close to
being worse here
okay six
improve the pawns a bit more
f6 it's just
just a dead draw
i feel like he's trying ever so slightly
to be worse here but
ah what's up i'll give him a little bit
of a spin
just try and provoke him you could have
gone d4 for that but
yeah he's he's not gonna get provoked at
all
okay
just that draw
okay he's on the scoreboard the sweep is
not on
but we got uh six games to go and i need
two points to advance
so i'm still
still feeling pretty
pretty good
okay
yeah let's play something else
the old london oh he goes bishop five